hold on to your bucks Jurassic Park is a
1993 Steven Spielberg film about a
billionaire loony in white linen who
builds a prehistoric West world that no
one will ever visit because it's too
expensive and the attractions eat people
it's one of the greatest action
adventure films of all time but after
watching it again we have some questions
how can we possibly have the slightest
idea what to expect
who is this kid what is he doing on an
archeological dig is the owner special
field trip for kids and tacky
Quicksilver shirts why does the rest of
the staff have to leave the island
because of the storm it wasn't even that
bad it just like rained a lot using
sophisticated techniques from the
mosquito sophisticated techniques looks
like a drill and a needle to me how
sophisticated is that also how did they
clone the plants they explained the
dinosaurs but never the plants is it
more of these sophisticated techniques
why did you narrow run from the Jeep to
the toilet did he honestly think he was
gonna be safer there why did ray go to
the maintenance shed alone had he never
seen another scary movie before
why do Allen and Tim climb straight down
this tree why not just whip around to
the other side you know the one where
the Jeep isn't falling behind them also
why does Tim climb the electric fence it
clearly could have fit between the wires
in fact he does so right here man
everyone in this movie is bad at
climbing
how does Tim know the Brachiosaurus a
cold has he seen a lot of healthy
Brachiosaurus you know in the six hours
dinosaurs have been real for him why
don't we buy Jeff Goldblum as a sexy
mathematician is it because he's not
sexy or because he's a mathematician can
those two words go together
why doesn't Tim hand Ellie the shotgun
he's not doing anything besides standing
around freaking out and not helping
anyone how does a 10-ton t-rex sneak
into a visitor center without anyone
noticing
everywhere else she goes she clumps
around like Frankenstein
but now she's some kind of ninja and
finally did you ever notice that
Jurassic Park has pretty much the same
ending as predator well the good news is
there's two sequels that do a great job
of not answering any of these questions
at all what do you think about that mr.
sexy math man that is one big pile of
[ __ ]